[Música]
Hola Mi nombre es Ángela Gómez y aquí
comienza ella el programa feminista de
France 24 en Estados Unidos se cumple un
año desde que la Corte Suprema revocó el
histórico fallo wave que protegía el
derecho al aborto en todo el territorio
esto ha derivado en la prohibición de la
interrupción del embarazo en 15 estados
al menos y la ampliación de
prohibiciones El fallo por ejemplo ha
obligado a las mujeres a viajar a
Estados con legislaciones más laxas y
aumentó la demanda de píldoras abortivas
que también estuvieron en el centro del
debate desde el último fallo vamos a
comenzar con un reporte de Manuela Cano
se trató de una decisión que dividió a
Estados Unidos el 24 de junio de 2022 la
Corte Suprema del país anuló el
histórico fallo Road versus White
vigente desde 1973 protegía el derecho
al aborto en todo el país la
determinación otorgó a cada estado la
Facultad de decidir sobre la
interrupción al embarazo así reaccionaba
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden
ahora con la caída de Row seamos muy
claros la salud y la vida de las mujeres
en esta nación ahora están en riesgo
un año después 14 estados tienen
prohibiciones casi totales de la
interrupción del embarazo además seis
estados han implementado la prohibición
del aborto después de las 6 a 20 semanas
los datos también revelan el efecto que
ha tenido sobre el acceso a dichos
procedimientos en la actualidad 17,5
millones de mujeres en edad reproductiva
es decir aproximadamente una cuarta
parte de las mujeres en ese grupo de
edad Residen en lugares donde el aborto
está prohibido o mayormente prohibido
según un reporte de society of family
planning en los dos meses anteriores a
la revocatoria la media mensual de
abortos practicados por médicos en
Estados Unidos Fue 81.730 mientras que
en los nueve meses posteriores la media
mensual de abortos fue de 79.031 un año
que también estuvo marcado por la
disputa legal de la mifepristona la
píldora abortiva con la que se realizan
cerca del 50% de los abortos en Estados
Unidos la Corte Suprema decidió mantener
su acceso luego de que un juez de Texas
restringiera su uso
el hecho de que un juez en un distrito
de un estado haya causado tanto caos en
todo el país es bastante preocupante
Y es que las píldoras han obtenido un
papel protagónico tras el fallo e
idacces una organización que brinda
acceso al aborto con medicamentos por
correo en Estados Unidos tuvo un
incremento del 120% solo en julio y
agosto de 2022 en la actualidad la
legislación sobre el aborto en Estados
Unidos compleja y parece que los cambios
no cesan solo en 2022 los legisladores
estatales introdujeron 563 disposiciones
para restringir el acceso al aborto la
anulación del fallo dejó a cada estado
la libertad para legislar sobre los
derechos del aborto y este tema se ha
convertido en otro polarizador en el
país un año después nosotros vamos a
conversar sobre los efectos de todo este
tema con Astrid ackerman ella es abogada
del centro de derechos reproductivos y
su trabajo se ha enfocado en litigar
Casos defendiendo el derecho al aborto y
también a la salud materna en cortes
federales y estatales en Estados Unidos
actriz de bienvenida a ella soy
Muchas gracias por la invitación
más o menos haciendo un mapa de los
Estados Unidos que es grandísimo en 26
estados sigue siendo legal por ahora y
en otros cuatro Que de momento no han
aprobado medidas más conservadoras al
respecto en cinco estados lo sigue
siendo para las fases iniciales del
embarazo estas son solamente algunas de
las cifras que también recoge nuestro
reporte y Quiero preguntarle Astrid para
comenzar Cuáles son las consecuencias de
este grandísimo abanico de restricciones
que además se torna muy confuso para la
ciudadanía
Así es la decisión de la corte ha tenido
consecuencias devastadoras para las
mujeres y las personas gestantes en este
país que se han visto ahora que
asuntos políticos están incidiendo sobre
sus decisiones de salud y lo que hemos
visto Es que después de la decisión de
la corte de revocar Robbie wade en los
primeros cien días solamente 66 clínicas
en 15 estados distintos tuvieron que
Cesar sus servicios también lo que hemos
visto es que en general para todas las
personas que necesitan un aborto en este
país el tiempo de traslado a una clínica
sea triplicado y en parte es esto que
Estados Unidos es un país muy grande
donde es muy difícil conseguir
transporte público y así poder Acceder
al aborto Bueno un tema es el abor libre
y seguro de los embarazos no deseados
pero otro tema muy importante tiene que
ver con el aborto terapéutico con
embarazos que en algún momento fueron
muy deseados pero que simplemente no son
viables le pongo un ejemplo entre miles
que suceden que el cuerpo de la madre no
desarrolla en su útero líquido amniótico
y por lo tanto pues es un bebé que no va
a prosperar pero con estas medidas de
prohibición pues mujeres que viven
situaciones como esta e incluso peores
Pues se quedan sin opciones para
finalizar su embarazo y finalmente las
están condenando a sufrir un montón de
dolores
con todo lo que eso trae hablemos sobre
esta parte de la historia un año después
Así es las consecuencias que estamos
viendo no son solamente para las
personas que tienen una embargazo no
deseado pero para las personas que
tienen un embarazo deseado y que sufren
emergencias obstétricas nosotras lo que
hemos estado haciendo es tratar de
luchar para proteger a estas personas y
a los proveedores y las proveedoras de
salud para para que puedan ofrecer
servicios de aborto en estos casos
Entonces estamos hablando de los estados
donde está completamente restringido por
ejemplo en Texas hemos
presentado una demanda legal con
varias mujeres que sufrieron emergencias
obstétricas en Texas y que no pudieron
Acceder al aborto en el estado y
tuvieron que huir huir del Estado huir
de Texas para poder Acceder al aborto en
otros países en otros estados y también
que tú que tuvieron efectos a su salud
debido a que tuvieron un aborto muy
tardío
y Dentro de este este fenómeno de los
traslados que usted menciona Astrid
quisiera que andemos un poco más porque
algo que se ha visto mucho si uno mira
el mapa de Estados Unidos es que las
clínicas que ofrecen servicios de aborto
se han movido muchas veces
estratégicamente fuera del Estado Pero
esto a veces puede representar
simplemente moverse a cinco minutos de
distancia simplemente cruzando una línea
invisible
Cómo ha sido esta nueva proliferación de
lugares que sí ofrecen el servicio de
aborto Porque de todas maneras ante la
dificultad si surge respuesta
claro ha surgido respuesta y nosotros
las como abogadas pero al mismo tiempo
las y los proveedores de salud han
estado tratando de
continuar protegiendo el derecho al
aborto independientemente del estado
donde donde vivan las personas
independientemente de su situación
financiera para que puedan tener acceso
a esta
este
salud que es básica y que es necesaria
demográficamente la mayoría de las
restricciones de aborto se han situado
en el último año hacia el sur del país
porque este fenómeno Y qué nos dice en
cuanto a la inclinación política de los
Estados
sí lo que es muy importante recalcar es
que es lo que estamos viendo Es que esto
no es una cuestión política en el
sentido de que es sobre el partido
demócrata o el partido republicano lo
que de verdad lo que importa es que esta
decisión de la Corte Suprema ha tenido
una
un daño catastrófico para millones de
personas en este país y sin embargo
Astrid Aunque no es un asunto político
sino que debería ser tratado como un
asunto de salud pública Finalmente sí
termina siendo una discusión que
politiza el derecho de las mujeres sobre
su propio cuerpo este tema ha estado en
juego en las elecciones de medio término
y con certeza va a estar en juego en las
elecciones presidenciales que se
avecinan usted cómo ve que este tema
podría marcar una balanza
si lo que yo quiero recalcar es que para
las personas que viven en estados donde
el aborto está prohibido esas personas
van a seguir teniendo y necesitando el
aborto Por qué Porque lo que clarifica
la situación en la que estamos en este
momento es que el aborto es salud
pública esencial y fundamental a la cual
todas y todos deberíamos de tener acceso
y para las personas que viven en estados
donde sí Es legal es importante seguir
protegiendo el aborto en esos estados
para que personas puedan tener puedan
poder ejercer su derecho a obtener un
aborto bueno astrilla Nos quedamos sin
tiempo nos queda menos de un minuto de
programa pero quiero preguntarle un año
después en su opinión donde estamos en
derechos de aborto en Estados Unidos
Sí es muy importante que ahora Estados
Unidos se encuentra en un marco
contrastante con el resto del mundo hay
una tendencia a nivel mundial la
liberalizar el aborto en los últimos 30
años De hecho 60 países han liberalizado
el aborto y solamente cuatro países y
ahora Estados Unidos se encuentra dentro
de sus cuatro países se han movido hacia
restringir y criminalizar el aborto
Pues yo le agradezco por ampliarnos el
panorama dentro del mapa de los Estados
Unidos y le deseo que tenga un feliz día
Muchas gracias Muy bien y a nuestros
televidentes nos veremos Próximamente en
France 24 y por supuesto en ellas hoy
[Música]